krasse überfall serie auf juweliere in
kalifornien in san jose stimmen gleich
neun männer mit hämmern bewaffnet in ein
kaufhaus schreien die menschen an sich
auf den boden zu reden dann schlagen sie
auf die glasvitrinen einholen so viel
schmuck wie möglich da raus
angestellte laufen panisch davon die
brutalität der männer ist erschreckend
dann nach etwa 30 sekunden verschwinden
sie wieder zum schnell um von der
polizei geschnappt zu werden die beute
umgerechnet fast 90.000 euro
die hammer ging hat bereits vor knapp
einer woche das kaufhaus bedroht konnte
da aber vom sicherheitspersonal gestoppt
werden nun der überfall und dieser ist
nur einer von vielen die derzeit den
bundesstaat heimsuchen
immer wieder kommt es in den letzten
wochen zu sogenannten smash angriff
stellen in kalifornien wie hier im
november in einem anderen juwelierladen
in der stadt concorde die polizei
ermittelt in alle richtungen
der sohn des geschäftsinhabers hat jetzt
diese videos auf facebook gepostet mehr
aufmerksamkeit zu erreichen er sagt es
muss etwas passieren damit solche
überfälle nie wieder stattfinden
[Musik]